if you're looking for ways to have a
good morning routine learn to outsource
and seize opportunities then this video
is for you
so here's why having a morning and
evening routine can help you be more
focused less stressed and more
successful now you hear the advice like
follow your passion like this is okay
device but you know I have a passion for
like eating pancakes that's not gonna
put food on the table so yeah wait plate
areas in your life where you know maybe
there's someone else that could do this
better than I need motivation watch a
top 10 would believe nation what's up
it's Evan my one word is believe and I
believe in you I believe in that amazing
gift you have inside you that I want to
see come out so let's get your
motivation to attend and get you
believing in you grab a snack and chew
on today's message from a man who grew
up in a suburb of Oklahoma City and
started the Art of Manliness website as
something fun to do in his spare time to
inspiring millions of men around the
world to become better men through his
website podcast books and YouTube
channel he's Brett McKay and here's my
take on his top ten rules of success
enjoy
all right so coming up first rule number
one is create for yourself
so I actually started the blog back in
2008 when I was a second-year law
student and it was just for fun real I
had no intentions of this becoming my my
living it's gonna be an attorney doing
oil and gas probably and the reason I
started it because I was tired of all
the other content being put out there
for men you know I subscribed to Men's
Health read Esquire and I was getting
tired of with men's health particularly
it was like every month is the exact
same thing I knew there's gonna be an
article about six-pack ABS you know
biceps biceps of course is always vices
sex position tips you know and then the
other men's lifestyle stuff out there it
was you know selling a lifestyle the
average guy couldn't afford and then the
bottom line it just didn't resonate with
me it's like this isn't manly right no
it's popular coke it's popular culture
and look and then even has a guy like I
was a law student grew up in the suburbs
I knew I wasn't incredibly manly I look
at my men like my grandfather
great-grandfather's they were like game
wardens you know for service guys can go
out in the mounds with nothing but a
pack horse for three weeks and survive
and come back and that just what they
were putting out there didn't resonate
with me so I decide you know what if
they're not gonna secrete the kind of
stuff that I want to read like I'll
create the stuff that I want I'd create
I wanted to make the men's magazine that
I want and this is doctor perder yep it
it exactly but yeah the problem there's
a problem here's a product I want yeah
it's not being offered to me for sale so
of creating how they ended it summarized
how so many businesses are created
there's a problem you go and you solve
it yourself why did I do the top tens
because I wanted to be around great
thinkers legendary entrepreneurs on a
daily basis so I made it for myself
instead of complaining that nobody else
is making it I made it and I heared it
with you guys and everybody wins create
for yourself let's move on to rule
number two do it yourself during this
time when I started blogging I knew
nothing about like web design I knew
nothing about HTML I knew nothing about
PHP and you're nothing about servers
graphic doesn't I knew
I mean I was a humanities major in in
college and I went to law school so
they're like this whole geek stuff just
I didn't know anything about but I
didn't have the money to buy an
expensive web design or have a nice
design and have the money to you know do
a lot of nice things that you can do
with a website so I had to learn
everything and do it myself so I had to
invest a lot of sweat equity so with the
frugal law student I learned how to do
Photoshop but I didn't use Photoshop I
use the poor man's Photoshop which is
[ __ ] that's what I didn't do my graphic
design I went to w3 schools to learn how
to do HTML and CSS I would you know
search the the WordPress you know forms
that are free there to figure out you
know okay I want to do this cool thing
but I can't do it how do you do this
with PHP and I've learned how to do that
there so yeah I really cut my teeth on
how to create a blog and run it and make
it look nice so here's another message
that comes up over and over and over
again instead of looking to complaining
about how you can't do this you don't
have those skills or that talent or that
gear that equipment you just find a way
you start small you do it yourself you
struggle your way through it you learn
enough to get it out and as you grow in
as you scale then you can bring people
on to help you do the things you don't
want to do at the start of my youtube
channel I did everything myself
everything and then the first person I
hired was an editor as soon as I could
afford it to allow me to go from a video
a week to a video a day and eliminate
that from my work process but at the
beginning you do it yourself you do what
you can with what you have
let's move the rule number three have a
good morning and evening routine so
here's why having a morning and evening
routine can help you be more focused
less stressed and more successful first
it ensures the really important things
get done well we generally can't control
what goes on in the middle of the day we
can usually control how we begin and end
our day so take advantage of this fact
by incorporating your most important
tasks actions and behaviors into your
morning and evening routines so for
example I know many businessmen who
refuse to check email first thing in the
morning instead their morning routine
consists of waking up getting dressed
and spending an hour working on their
most important tasks of the day even
before they get into the office this
ensures they accomplish their task
before the chaos and interruptions
workday get in the way now for me if I
don't exercise first thing in the
morning I won't exercise that day I just
don't have time for it
so daily exercise is part of my morning
routine journal writing is another
important thing for me and if I don't
set aside a specific time just for
journaling it just doesn't get done thus
journal writing is part of my evening
routine I love that he talks about
having a morning and evening routine
because when you can get into the habit
of doing the things that consistently
set you up for success it eliminates a
variability it eliminates you having a
great day being motivated and then you
fall back down the earth and the rest of
your week kind of sucks you want every
day to set yourself up for success and
so instead of waking up like an accident
every single day you wake up and do the
things that are triggers for you habits
for you to allow you to have an amazing
day whatever that requires for you let's
go to rule number four plan your week
are there any a specific productivity of
pieces or anything that is like really
add in to your life you know I'm one of
those guys who like toys around with
different productivity systems and
what's frustrating I know it's not like
one system is better than the other
system at our sticky with it so one
thing that I found that helps me a lot
is just plenty now my week sitting down
Sundays are usually a good day for that
looking at the week ahead planning out
the big important things the things that
you know are non-negotiable
non-negotiable and scheduling those out
and then scheduling around everything
else around those big big blocks yes
that's one of the things that's helped
me out a lot and then also everyday just
reviewing your calendar and your to-do
list
you know I
today see what you got done and see what
needs to be done the next that's helped
out a lot first off is great to see
Antonio Centeno in this video he has an
amazing YouTube channel called real men
real style that I recommend you checking
out I met up with him earlier this year
in Los Angeles area and he's a great
dude on top of being a great youtuber in
terms of planning your week I totally
agree I think you only have so much
capacity every day to wake up and think
about what you're gonna do if you're
waking up every morning then thinking
what you're gonna do that day then
you've already lost you need to wake up
and do where you need to spend 90% of
your time doing and 10% of your time to
thinking so you spend time once a week
trying to figure out what's gonna happen
this next week does this calendar serve
my higher ambitions am i doing the thing
that's gonna allow me to reach my goals
and then every day you wake up and you
just go out and do the plan execute the
plan and stop getting in your own way
with your thinking let's go to rule
number five seize opportunities no you
hear the advice like follow your passion
so I guess is okay device but you know I
have a passion for like eating pancakes
that's not gonna put food on the table I
think you know the more most successful
entrepreneurs or content producers they
they see a need and they fill it like
before I start this I wasn't
particularly passionate about manliness
like I wanted to be a better man
I wasn't obsessing about it but I saw
that there was a need and an open an
opening for what I for something that I
wanted to what I saw was missing and so
I did it I think you need to combine
both if you want to have a successful
business it's got to be something that
you love doing and there's a market for
it has to be both and if you watch the
first clip again I think you'll see some
quality passion coming up for why he
wanted to start this business let's jump
to rule number six improve your physical
fitness I just did an interview with
this guy dude watch Band of Brothers
I've seen you've seen I've seen parts of
the parts of the miniseries well there
was a guy in there dick winners he was
one of the the commanders an easy
company during the band of brothers and
so the guy talk to you about dick
winners write his memoirs before he died
mmm-hmm and I thought this really
interesting dick winners the guy was
just phenomenal he was
a phenomenal leader but he really hit on
the point that physical fitness physical
strength was the basis of being a good
leader like because it carries over to
other aspects and what was crazy was you
know even when he's at training camp he
would run two extra miles right because
he didn't have to but he brought how to
do that even during he was in the battle
and he wanted his his they don't see
that right exactly and even during when
he was in battle over in Europe he still
found time to take a two-mile hike maybe
a two mile jog in the morning before the
battle started just to keep that
discipline going because he felt that
physical fitness physical strength was
the basis of you know just good
discipline and that carried over into
other into the into the battle of the
more effective soldier and warrior so
that's an interesting perspective that
physical fitness allows you to be a more
effective leader
I gotta think more on that I could think
of a lot of leaders who are great
leaders who are not really physically
fit but does that mean that they could
be a better leader if they were more
physically fit I'd love to know what you
guys think and if you have any research
to share let me know in the comments
let's go to rule number seven learn to
outsource we've got some guy out there
and he is working a hundred hours a week
he has two kids he's just trying to
figure out how to you know how to how to
balance that's better one thing is learn
to outsource that's one thing I know
that they have done it's like if there's
things that someone else can do better
than you and you can you know better
than you let them let that person do it
like if you need an accountant instead
of handling the books you're so you'll
not just talk you're not talking talking
like you know
if you have someone if you're doing your
own books getting by getting an
accountant the best things I ever did
one of the best choice decision that
makes like keeping the books that took
so much time I taxes to it forever
because when you have a business that
you're taxing becomes something more
complicated so it's nice having a
professional no I mean my accountant
more than pays for yourself yeah I guess
she adds things I would never exactly
tax code is not logical no it's not it's
not they save you money at tax time too
but just saving you time on the
bookkeeping yes one thing so yeah find
way it plate areas in your life where
you know maybe there's someone else that
could do this better than I could and I
can spend my time on what I'm good at
you know that's one another thing I
would recommend doing for sure
I think this rule pairs really well rule
number two which was do-it-yourself
it's like well how does that make sense
do-it-yourself ain't outsourced at the
beginning you do everything yourself you
have to learn how to do the bookkeeping
you have to learn how to do Photoshop
you have to learn everything you need to
know to get your business off the ground
so you start making money but as soon as
you start making some money that's
coming in then you need to start
delegating and outsourcing so you can
focus on what you have Michael Jordan
level talent at and go all-in on that
and give everything else to the other
people on your team all right it's time
for rule number eight develop good
habits good habits allow us to make real
progress in our lives instead of
choosing the right thing being something
we find endlessly difficult and
frustrating positive behaviors become
automatic and what we gain is secured to
us Aristotle said that virtue is
something that we've talked a lot about
on the site was essentially the habit of
right dealing at the same time bad
habits can be a huge millstone that
prevents us from becoming the men we
want to be they can keep us seemingly
locked into a pattern of automatic
behavior that keeps our goals ever out
of reach and here's an initiative thing
about our brains once a bad habit
becomes itched in our brains they never
really disappear but we can override
them with the good habit to change your
habits you first need to understand how
they function the habit loop is a
three-step process described by Charles
Duhigg in his
with a power of habit it's a book I
highly recommend you go and pick up
first there's a queue this is a trigger
that sets off your automatic behavior
this can be a physical location a smell
other people or an emotional state the
cue sets off a routine or a set of
behaviors in the routine leads to a
reward so cue routine reward so for
example let's say every afternoon you
get up from your desk and grab a Diet
Mountain Dew and then you chug it the
cue is how you feel in the afternoon the
routine is getting up and drinking the
dew and the reward is how you feel
afterwards but we'll cover more about
that in a minute you see the reward is
what keeps you repeating the loop until
it becomes a firmly entrenched habit and
you barely think about what you're doing
anymore as we encounter this three-part
habit loop over and over again the
process slowly becomes more and more
automatic and firmly entrenched in our
minds research has shown that by
becoming aware of the habit loop in our
lives and making simple tweaks to it we
can change bad habits to good ones to
change a habit you must simply follow
the golden rule of habit change keep the
cue and reward change the routine that's
it
it sounds simple but if you're delivered
about it it can really work here's a
step by step guide that Charles Duhigg
suggests using to hack your habit loop
step 1 identify the routine the first
step is to identify the routine you want
to change in your life you know for
example if you want to stop checking
your email incessantly you want to stop
watching porn every night how about
quitting your caffeine habit or maybe
you want to quit playing video games all
work weekend and start working out this
is the part of the habit loop that will
be tweaking in order to change our
undesirable habits step 2 identify the
reward it may seem easy to identify the
rewards of our habits could be like
nachos orgasm distraction but what
you're actually craving may be different
and it may be possible to satisfy that
deeper craving in a more positive way
step 3 identify the cue once you
identify the reward it's time to
identify the cue it's that thing that
triggers the craving remember cues can
be things like location
a time and emotional state other people
or some immediate preceding action
whenever you get the urge for mountain
dew write down answer that correspond to
the five possible q categories do this
for an entire week after a while you
should be noticing a reoccurring q for
example you may find that you get a
craving for mountain dew whenever you
started feeling sleepy in the afternoon
step 4
create a plan after you identify the cue
and reward you can start making plans to
change your routine by creating what's
called an implementation intention an
implementation intention is an if-then
phrase that links it's situational cue
to a specific action for example to kick
your Mountain Dew habit you can create
an implementation like this when I feel
tired at 2:00 p.m. I will get up and
walk around outside for 15 minutes
you'll need to be methodical about
actually implementing your
implementation intention depending on
how entrenched your bad habit was
overriding it with your new good habit
could take a few weeks be patient stick
to your implementation intention and
change will come the final ingredient
necessary for lasting habit changes to
believe that change is possible
researchers have found that the best way
to foster that belief in yourself is to
surround yourself as a supportive group
of people if you can find an
accountability partner that you can
check in with about your progress so I
really love this point habit change is
something that's really current for me
what I'm thinking about how to really
hack my habits I have the same book I
actually just started reading it so you
can see here's my bookmark I've actually
just started reading it so that was an
awesome overview that I'm now looking to
dive deep in on the actual book but for
now let's keep it going - rule number 9
get feedback instead of seeing criticism
as humiliating or embarrassing view it
as an opportunity to improve yourself
Winston Churchill had this to say about
criticism criticism may not be agreeable
but it is necessary if it fills the same
function as pain the human body it calls
attention to an unhealthy state of
things
now instead of avoiding criticism seek
for opportunities to receive
constructive feedback from others you'll
find that getting feedback from an
outside source will strengthen your
talents and abilities I think as long as
you can use feedback as a kick forward
and not a kick down when you get
criticism you use that to make yourself
better instead of feeling sorry for
yourself to kick forward not to kick
down
super important to getting effective
feedback to help grow yourself and your
business it's time for rule number ten
before we get to the bonuses harness
your inner lumberjack Lumberjacks are a
manly Bunch all that axe swinging and
heavy log lifting has put them in peak
physical condition to harness your inner
lumberjack we've put together a workout
program inspired by these men of the
woods so put on your flannel shirt and
boots grab your axe and head outside
it's time to do the woodsmen workout
deep breathing begin your woods been
workout with some deep breathing
exercises to clear the mind and
oxygenate your blood for the vigorous
activity you're about to take part in
take 20 deep breaths focus on the sound
of your breath and the bubbling brook
beside you hiking hiking serves as the
foundation of the Woodsman workout in
between the various exercises we're
constantly moving because we're
constantly hiking keep a brisk pace
while you hike but make sure to take
some breaks to really soak in the
scenery perform each of the exercises
below whenever nature moves to do so and
as soon as you finish the exercise start
hiking again immediately front log squat
as you're hiking and taking in the view
be on the lookout for logs for hefting
and hoisting squats are a great way to
develop the lower body strength needed
for powering through long heights and
putting unruly moose in leg locks hoist
the log from the ground and into your
arms the log should be resting as high
up on your arms as it can and squat to
parallel do three sets of eight reps
overhead log press shoulder presses are
great exercises and they're even
awesomer when performed with a giant
tree log the logs girth makes the lift a
bit more difficult because you have to
activate different muscles to maintain
hold the log during the lift perform
three sets of eight bear-crawl harness
the power of your animal spirit guide
the noble bear by performing bear crawls
through the woods just get down on all
fours and crawl like a bear perform the
bear crawl in one-minute Sprint's
whenever you feel like it during your
hike Boulder tossing you've probably
seen people tossing medicine balls in
the gym the equivalent of that in the
woodsmen workout is Boulder tossing
tossing heavy boulders is a full-body
workout you work your back chest legs
and arms shoulders and core best of all
it's fun to throw heavy things around in
the woods
the lumberjack press the lumberjack
press is a great shoulder exercise it
also activates your core muscles in
order to keep the log straight and
balanced during the lift complete two
sets of five wood splitting a woodsman
workout wouldn't be complete without a
session of wood splitting splitting a
stack of wood is a tremendous workout
you work your arms back and core
swinging them all around it also is a
great high intensity cardio workout well
there you go the woodsman workout now go
refill your body with a big stack of
flapjacks until next time this is Brett
Mackay telling you to stay manly I love
this video I don't know if I'm gonna go
harness my inner lumberjack just quite
yet but I think it just speaks to when
you are yourself
when you bring a different vibe your own
flavor to your videos it can really help
make a difference it can really help
connect with people and so stop being
boring and stop being corporate and stop
being professional and start being you
so thank you guys so much for watching I
think I would say rule number eight is
my personal favorite the one about
habits because again I'm reading the
book and I'm all in on the habit zone
right now I love to know from you was
rule number eight your favorite or is
there a better one that had a more
immediate impact on you leave it on the
comments below I'm really curious to
find out I also want to thank Liam bass
for recommending that we do this video
thank you so much Liam and if you guys
watching have a request for a future top
ten video check out the link in the
description and you can go and cast your
vote on the request line video and
finally I want to give a quick shoutout
to tyrone Voss Tyrone thank you so much
you're buying one of my shirts this
shirt the entrepreneur rebel shirt and
posting it on the Twitter I really
appreciate it man thank you so much your
support and where your shirt proudly
thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one where it is much love I'll see you
soon
one of the things with running the Art
of Manliness and being the owner of it I
think a lot of love's expectation like
I'm like this expert on manliness and
I've tried not to put myself out there
as an expert on what it means to be a
man really I'm trying to figure this
whole thing out along with everyone else
all I do is I'll research it and learn
about it and then I just share what I
learned with other with other guys
I get those emails to like I can't wait
to meet you in person and I'm always
fairly disappoint them when they
actually made me look oh man
Brett's just like a regular guy like
anybody else and it's like well I am a
regular guy like anybody else you just
have to be the best you can be when
you're when you present yourself be the
best you you can be nothing more nothing
less
and don't worry some of if someone else
had this inflated expectation of you you
know that's that's on them right that's
not your concern I just got to do the
best that you can with with yourself the
best thing about what we do is getting
the emails and the letters from people
saying you know your site changed my
life that's those are the most like
that's why you do it you know that's
that makes up for all the trolls and
people who come on your site saying this
is the stupidest thing in the world why
would you read a blog about how to be a
man but you get those guys you're like
man I was in a bad place in my life but
you know your articles spired me get off
my butt and do something more that
that's that's that's the best part of
what we do raise your standard Apple at
the core whose core values
is that we believe that people your
passion can change the way people not
one drop of myself work depends on your
it's supposed to mean
I don't ever give up I'd have to be dead
or completely incapacitated hey believe
nation if you want to see my all-time
favorite top ten roses success
I have a very special secret video for
you these are the individual clips that
I have personally learned the most from
and applied to my life and my business
check the link the description for
details